c'est la première rencontre avec sa
conseillère xavier a fait le chemin de
croissy sur seine jusqu'à cette agence
retraite de saint quentin en yvelines
une étape indispensable pour préparer
son passage à la retraite
je fais une demande de retraite paul
asie vais donc y avait effectivement des
compléments d'information je lui ai
besoin pour pouvoir avoir un dossier
plein complet pour pouvoir démarrer
correctement son bon pied bon j'ai eu
des précisions en particulière sur
comment ça a pu se dérouler c'est un
chaque jour cette agence s'occupe d'une
centaine de personnes qui comme xavier
se prépare à partir à la retraite
les assurés sont reçus sans rendez vous
mais à partir du 2 juin les modalités
d'accueil évolue désormais les assurés
seront obligés de prendre rendez vous
avec un conseiller
un service sur mesure cela nous
permettra de conserver ce moment
privilégié parce que le passage à la
retraite et comme la main moment un peu
anxiogène que nous allons privilégier ce
mode de contact
nous répondons à une vraie demande
aujourd'hui les assurés
vienne patiente en salles d'attentes
pour obtenir leurs informations
la saa permettra d'avoir un conseil
personnalisé pour prendre rendez-vous
direction le site internet de
l'assurance retraite dans un souci de
modernisation
le site se veut également plus
informatif pour éviter aux assurés de se
déplacer en agence
l'an dernier plus de 600 13000 personnes
ont pris leur retraite